- Would you do a like a reboot?
Like a third, a third time over?
- A reboot?
- A reboot.
- Yeah, I mean--
- Reboot.
I love the show!
- Thank you.
We love--
- I love it!
- Doing it.
We shoot on this lot.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's been great.
I mean, people use to ask me years ago,
"Would you do it again?"
But the word reboot didn't exist.
It was like, reboots were like--
- [Kelly] It's everywhere now.
- A Very Brady Christmas.
Was that, you know what I mean.
There wasn't like the show done again.
So this has been so great,
and, yes, we'd do it again.
We'd probably have to
call it The Golden Girls.
But but it's--
(audience laughs)
- You should do The Golden Boys.
- The Golden--
- You can do the Golden,
and use your beard.
- Yes, the next, if there's--
- You can be the youngest.
- If there's another reboot, Will is
definitely getting the beard,
'cause I'm getting too lazy.
- Oh my God, that is a show for men.
To do Golden Girls, but a (Kelly murmurs).
I'm just saying, I just came up with it.
Use it.
- Sure, sure.
- I'm, you're welcome.
If I sell that next week
you would sue me.
- One word, one third.
That's the Nashville way.
I'm just kidding.
How did you celebrate
the last show ending?
- Years ago, well so
that's kinda hard to
remember what that was.
But we all wanted to steal stuff.
I mean that's what you wanna do, you know?
But Max, this is the whole
reason the reboot exists.
Max Mutchnick, who created the show,
moved the entire set to
his alma mater, in Boston.
Emerson College, which is where it's
been standing for 10 years,
in tact, everything on it.
- What?
- And when they finally said,
"Did you take your set back?"
That's when he said, "I'm
gonna reboot this show."
And took the flew the
set across the country.
But the thing I wanted, there it was,
it showed up again two
years ago on the set.
I was staring at it.
And this what happened was, our very
first interview we ever did in 1998.
Donny and Marie came to visit the set.
- Wow!
- And Donny had these
questions on blue cards, and
just as they were rolling,
he shoved them into a box
on Will's coffee table.
Which remained there, not only for
our entire eight year run,
but for the 10 years that
it was at Emerson College.
And the set came back,
we set up over here,
and I turned to my producer.
I said, "If Donny Osmond's questions are
in that box, I'm taking it."
And there they were, 20 years later.
(audience sighs)
Yeah, isn't that funny?
- What!
(audience applauds)
That's kind of nuts!
That somebody wouldn't have stolen them!